[Music]
i'm back
chuck i know well that means it's time
to talk about something that you thought
you knew but you didn't really know
everything you thought you know about or
even if you never knew
to think anything about it sometimes
there's those things as well
uh you know one of our most successful
of these was on
water towers wasn't that amazing it's
got millions and millions
of views and nobody thinks about
watertown
so it's just but it's a reminder that
there's physics in everything
so today today i want to talk about the
rocket equation
did you know that did you know there was
such a thing come on now
no you could say i'm sure there's an
equation for everything yeah i'm sure
there is yeah that's got to be right
well actually one of our friends of star
talk um
max tegmark uh he he wrote a book
a little while back on uh
why he felt we're all in a simulation
and one of the
the evidence for that was everything
that you see
happening in the world can be described
mathematically mathematically right
even a rock even barack yeah what do you
talk about
the forces and pressures within it that
comprise it and make it so if everything
can be described mathematically
then why can't we just all be in a
simulation where someone
programmed it in right and and it was
like i had no rebuttal
to that so you would expect even in that
world
the rockets would have their own
equation and they do
okay all right all right so here's how
it goes have you
ever wondered why
let's take the saturn v rocket for
example all right
for those who remember it or we can do
the the space shuttle any rocket at all
but the saturn 5 is sort of the best
a measure of what i'm about to describe
right
okay the rocket was 34 stories tall
yeah okay 34 stories right and
all right uh where were the astronauts
in half a story
they are crammed into the capsule
right way at the top okay okay
so well what's the rest of it is it
payload is it
their food supply for while they're on
the moon
no that sits just behind them a little
bit in the rest of the command module
okay there's a little b section they're
sitting up front to three of them
and there's a little sort of store
called storage closet
oh my god it's like a cosmic tractive
trailer
okay so there it is everything else
is rocket fuel that's ridiculous
everything
and you can say to yourself well how
come cars don't look like that
right all right if you if you're going
on a trip how come
most of your car is not it's not your
gas tank
it's not your gas tank that's just not
the case by the way
i am not getting in a car that is
98 gas tank
if you pull up in a car that's 98 gas
tank i'm like
bruh i'm taking the bus i will see i'll
see you when we get there i'll walk i'll
still get there that's right
all right so so here's what's going on
a rocket uh
when you launch you say well how much
fuel do i need to launch a certain
amount of payload
okay because that's it's all about the
payload all right
how you know the astronauts i forgot
which mission where they first took the
rover
uh you know their automobile on the moon
uh i heard jerry seinfeld joke about
this
he said you know guys
invented this idea say why because here
you have a rocket
going to the moon and the first thing
they said is let's bring a car
just the car culture in america is like
written all over that
you know we you gotta rock it guys so
you're not happy enough with that
that makes sense that's funny so
uh so here's the point we have the
payload and it weighs whatever it does
you say how much fuel does it take
to get that payload to the mu to the
moon okay
so you can calculate that and it'd be
like this much fuel i'm just gesturing
with my fingers here i'm not
the amount doesn't matter for what i'm
about to describe so that's how much
fuel it takes to get to the moon
all right but there's a problem chuck
the pay the weight of the payload is not
only the stuff you're bringing to the
moon
right it's the stream also the weight of
the fuel
you haven't burned yet right so now
i need more fuel to get my fuel
correct that gets my stuff to the moon
thank you
okay so you need the fuel to get the
fuel
to burn the fuel to get your stuff to
the moon
now that bit that you added
what's getting that to the moon now i
need my fuel to get my fuel that's
getting my fuel
to get my stuff to the moon exactly
okay so the branch of math called
calculus
is exquisitely conceived for just
this kind of problem okay all right
and so what it tells you is that the
amount
of fuel you need okay to deliver a
certain payload
grows exponentially okay
cool for every extra pound of payload
that's why
the birth of the space program you had
trim astronauts that we had to
miniaturize everything and in fact the
miniaturization of electronics
which we all take for granted today you
got stuff that fits on your hip
in your pocket going back to the sony
walkman where you put a cassette tape
and you walk around
the miniaturization of electronics was
driven
by the urge to put this stuff in space
wow
and so not this not sony walkman in
space but just just circuits and
the things that enable electricity to do
interesting and important things for you
on your journey
right so the urge to miniaturize it and
make it lighter and lighter and lighter
because you you couldn't keep making a
bigger and bigger gas tank
okay so that that's what it was
so you get the the slimmest possible
payload
now there's nothing an engineer likes
better than constraints
never you know think about it that way
engineer says what do i have to do i
need you to do xyz lmnop
okay and you but you have to do it for
this much money on
this time frame and you can only use
copper zinc
and aluminum okay that's where
ingenuity comes in right okay and that
is also why architects hate engineers
they've had they've been tussling from
from the beginning absolutely
so i saw jokes about that with the
sphinx back in ancient egypt
um it's like no you can't have the nose
stick out over the front it's not gonna
work we're gonna do it
the nose falls off oh that's hilarious
doesn't have a nose
that's a funny engineering toe guy right
there's nothing holding up the nose
right
it's just exactly that's dangling out
there
so the sphinx snazz
that's very funny okay go ahead all
right so there's a couple of
things we can do about this okay because
it's all about the weight
oh by the way i forgot this if you have
a gas
tank and then all the fuel has been
exhausted from that tank but you have
other tanks um
the empty tank has weight yes
so what are you gonna do now now it's
just not right now it's just a
it's useless so you just it's useless
useless okay so werner von braun knew
this
werner von braun was the the german
rocket engineer that we brought over
after the second world war
and we said build us a rocket to the
moon and so he did
and he realized that you don't want to
carry useless weight with fuel that you
need to ultimately get your payload
so he built the rocket into multiple
stages
it's brilliant multi-stage rocket so
the first stage is the first set of fuel
that burns and there it goes
it gets up to a certain speed a certain
altitude it is
done what do you do with that stage
jettison it
right you say get it the hell off of my
ass here
okay then you kick in the next stage oh
god i wish nasa talked like that
okay god that'll be so great mission
control we have reached the altitude of
all right get that off your ass
so anything you're not gonna use get it
the hell off of your body
right so you shed the shell the rocket
shell
and so so if you're high up and you shed
it it'll burn up in the atmosphere
now what what um spacex is doing
is for the set of rockets that jettison
low enough to not burn up okay
you know what they do they left some
fuel in them for them to
guide their way back autonomously to a
launch pad
and then they've reused them that's even
more brilliant that's that's there it is
and a bit scary why because i got used
rockets that i'm going to space with
no you refurbish them no no wait wait
chuck when you get in an airplane are
you saying wait has this airplane ever
been used before
no but that airplane has never been to
space before
and i'm not going to space okay so
i'm just saying all right but
okay but you do get on an airplane
that's been used a gazillion times
before that's true
that's if you had to if you if every
time you got on it you got off an
airplane
they threw away the airplane that's a
different business model
and your airplane ticket would cost a
whole lot more if that's what was going
on
[Laughter]
i only flying planes once okay
if you reuse things then you get the the
the benefits of the economy of scale for
that and that is
the main contribution that spacex is
making to this whole enterprise
okay so they reuse the rockets that they
jettison the remaining fuel has less
weight to then push to its destination
it's utterly brilliant okay so just to
be clear
the rocket that went to the moon needed
enough fuel
to leave earth go into orbit leave
earth orbit go to the moon go into orbit
around the moon land on the moon
come back to moon orbit leave earth moon
orbit and come back to earth
all that fuel had to be in that vessel
okay and they're just leaving stuff left
and right so on the moon they left
the landing pad they left the rovers
they brought some rocks
but and so by the time they got back
they just did the capsule
that was there at the top of the 36 to
34-storey building
okay that's yeah okay so now the reason
why
you don't have cars with 98
of their mass and fuel by the way you
would need such a car if you were
driving from
here to california where in new york now
if you're not from here to california
and there were no fill-in stations you'd
have to carry
all your fuel that's right and you would
and
some of the energy burned in that fuel
would be to move not only your ass and
your luggage and your family
but the other fuel that is not yet to
burn that's right
in fact the gas mileage for those still
using
internal combustion engine cars the gas
mileage of your car
gets better the less gas you have in the
tank
right because it's pushing something
it's fueling something that's lighter
it's lighter precisely and so i when i
was
on a budget and i had to work i actually
calculated that and i would save a few
dollars a month
by driving half empty down to like a
fifth empty rather than a full tank
down to half tank so anyhow did you also
calculate how to draft trucks
so you could save i did that once no no
watch
watch no no the problem is this doesn't
work in space that's the problem because
it requires air
all right there you go right but but um
my first car that i got that actually
told you your active
miles per gallon in a readout okay they
calculated that
right so i could see when i'm
accelerating hard the miles per gallon
drops as you'd expect
cruising that's higher so i said let me
try something
i went up behind a big old 18 wheeler
and
i got closer and closer and closer to it
now it can't see me in its rear view
mirrors
right so it doesn't know i'm there i
didn't feel safe doing this but it was
for science
okay so i did that and as i got closer i
watched the miles per gallon go up
and at one time at one point in there i
was getting 100 miles a gallon
oh that's great yeah because you were
just using their
all of the uh i was drafting off the
office off the truck that's
that's cool that's cool anyhow so the
real way to travel through space
just to bring this to closure is you
need filling stations in space
that way i don't need all that fuel i
just need fuel to get to the filling
station
now while these filling stations have
mini marts
i need a candy bar
you pull up hey can you can you check
the oil all right
tuck the oil i'm going to go inside and
get some chips and juice
[Laughter]
so the future of space travel is going
to have to be that or
you find a way to make fuel at your
destination and there are people
thinking about that for mars
uh mars especially um but also the moon
which has
fewer chemical resources but anyhow the
rocket equation tells you how big ass
your
rocket has to be because it's the fuel
that carries the fuel that carries the
fuel that carries the fuel that carries
your stuff
that's pretty cool and calculus makes
that a continuous equation
where you make the calculation perfect
and we've been doing that ever since the
dawn
of the space program chuck we got to
call it quits there
all righty there you go now you know how
to get to mars
yes i do practice
all right as always keep looking